[Música]
los economistas tenemos un montón de
manías o ciertos que nos gusta medir
todo pero todo todo todo cuando llega la
factura la factura de la luz a casa yo
me pongo a mirar el consumo de la
barrita que te llega para dar cuántos
kilowatts consumidos con suerte este mes
y te lo comparo con el mismo mes pero
del año anterior cuando abro mi heladera
una heladera que es conocida salvo esto
te estás
esta ladera cuando yo le hablo en miró
el estante de los yogures no es normal
me pongo a mirar la fecha de vencimiento
de los yogures y si están rotando los
sobres como tienen que rotar
eleconomista
cuando va al supermercado va con el
chango se para y no te mira solamente el
precio que aún va a tratar de esperar a
ver si ve la gente en el sector de
alimentos y bebidas para poder estimar
el consumo agregado a nivel nacional de
alimentos y bebidas de la argentina
bueno yo sé esto suena raro saben porque
suena raro porque somos gente bastante
rara
claro
lo cierto es que
la
y vea de medir todo todo todo todo
no se termina ahí también tenemos pasión
es mi pasión es enseñar yo soy
básicamente un profesor universitario
doy clase en la facultad porque tiendo
que enseñar es el mejor modo de
compartir
porque es la mejor manera de devolverle
a mi foco al agua a mi país lo que me
dio formándome de manera gratuita esa es
mi pasión y esa pasión
es el modo que yo creía que tenía para
participar y ticos decís cuál es tu
granito de arena qué vas a aportar a la
sociedad y yo participaba del modo que
me sentía más cómodo en los claustros en
la academia pero
no me estaba dando cuenta que había un
lugar muy cerquita en el que podía
participar y no lo estaba haciendo y de
eso vengo a hablar hoy con ustedes de la
maravillosa elección que me dio una
mujer
ella a ver si la podemos ver y se la
presentó
esa es la gringa
es mi compañera de vida
maría es madre soltera de segundo
es mi hijo del corazón
mariah al igual que
y muchas otras mujeres a través de la
situación que en realidad atraviesan más
de 1.100.000 madres solteras en nuestro
país todos los días
creo a su hijo sola
así le faltó nada fue a la escuela fue
la plaza y sus amigos jugó corrió se rió
lloró creció
hacemos lo ni faltó el regalo de
cumpleaños ni el regalo de navidad
y claro iban al cine el fin de semana
pero para eso está leon a ella sólo ella
y nadie más que se iba a trabajar todos
los días
más de una vez eligió volver caminando a
casa del trabajo porque podía ahorrar la
plata del subte o del colectivo para
juntar para el fin de semana
más de una vez eligió dormir un ratito
menos para quedarse con su guapa
un ratito más mire lo que era
sabían por qué porque ya tenía claro que
el otro día había quiero trabajar y el
tiempo que ganaba conseguía upa de otro
modo no lo podía recuperar
nadie más que ella le lavaba el
guardapolvos cuando volviera de la
escuela nadie más se va a las reuniones
de padres nadie más le compraba las
zapatillas
pasó el tiempo y cuando ya hablamos de
esta parte de esta etapa de su vida
no me lo cuenta como algo particular
como un esfuerzo especial siempre lo veo
normal
lo cierto es que bueno formamos una
familia
hoy la gringa
cam y sophie según yo
y nuestros cuatro perros hace seis años
que vivimos juntos ahora que somos muy
felices
y desde que vivimos juntos la historia
cambió
pero no tanto
cuando empezamos a vivir juntos el
tiempo pasaba y yo miraba sin ver cuando
llegaba a casa me sentaba en el sillón
miraba la tele jugaba con los chicos
leía
pero no como lavar la ropa del placard
y no participaba a la limpieza del hogar
cuando cocinaba era el evento cocina
todo
todo lo que hacía bien fuera de casa
pero estaba olvidando con mi familia
y si bien es cierto que victoria nos da
una mano la principal responsable de las
tareas del hogar seguirá siendo maría
que más de una vez
salía corriendo del trabajo para llegar
a casa para hacer las mismas cosas que
hacía cuando vivía con según solá bueno
todo normal
no eso no tiene nada de normal
como les dije
me gusta medir todo
entonces me puse a mirar lo que era
evidente que iba a encontrar que la no
participación de los varones en las
tareas domésticas tiene consecuencias
concretas en la vida de las mujeres
y la primera dice
se ve lo que se llama la brecha en la
tasa de actividad
miren si formaremos una fila de los
valores que trabajan lo que busca el
trabajo que pertenecen al mundo del
empleo esa fila sería 20 por ciento más
larga que la fila de las mujeres
20 por ciento más larga que la fila de
las mujeres
el rol de las niñas y las mujeres en el
cuidado de la familia en el mundo
termina repercutiendo en que relegan
posibilidades de empleo
de formación de desarrollo personal y
hasta de participación política en sus
comunidades
es que esto es un factor clave que
explica cómo tenemos que pensar la
extensión de la jornada laboral de las
mujeres porque no compiten del mismo
modo que nosotros los varones
las mujeres en la argentina llevan
adelante el 74 por ciento de las tareas
domésticas
eso tiene una traducción en horas saben
si van a ser hasta cuatro horas por día
y es trabajo no remunerado es trabajo no
remunerado
y claro tiene otra consecuencia la
consecuencia está en otra brecha la
brecha salarial
a diferencia de sueldo entre lo que gana
un balón y una mujer
cuando reflexionamos sobre las brechas
de género ni la profesión ni el lugar de
trabajo tienen tanto impacto como las
normas sociales cuántas veces escuchamos
no lo vas a tomar a esa chica porque el
día de mañana jovencita se embaraza
tiene tres meses de ciencia más tres
meses más después de un año sin venir
viste cómo son las mujeres viste cómo
son las mujeres
cuando se compite por un cargo gerencial
cuantas veces apareció el comentario la
es brillante lápida de brillante pero
sabes qué pasa tiene previstos sale
corriendo de acá de la oficina se va
temprano tiene que llevar a los chicos e
inglés
tiene que llevar a los chicos inglés
pero si tienes que ir a mirar un club de
barrio a ver cuántas mamás hay por cada
papá del fútbol un papá cinco mamás
y ustedes piensan que eso es gratis no
tiene consecuencias económicas esta
brecha salarial de las que yo les
mencionaba recién
miremos algunas diferencias
si hablamos de instrucción primaria
completa por cada 100 pesos que ganamos
los varones una mujer gana menos de 68
al mismo nivel de formación un varón que
gana 100 pesos supone una mujer que gana
cuando hablamos de universitario
completo probando esto que decíamos que
no importan en la profesión y el lugar
de trabajo que es una
norma social y cultural universitario
completo la las relaciones cada 100
pesos que ganamos los varones la mujer
gana 79 y medio mismo trabajo misma
responsabilidad 20 por ciento de
diferencia para abajo en las mujeres
qué vamos a hacer con esta brecha de
género
como podemos dar pasos para empezar a
cerrar una diferencia que tiene siglos
en la historia de la humanidad
yo creo que empieza por cada uno de
nosotros yo creo que es un desafío
cultural
de verdad me parece que esta vez no se
trata de barajar y dar de vuelta tenemos
que intentar cambiar la baraja
puede preguntar qué puede hacer la
gringa por mí yo tengo que preguntar mi
equipo hacer yo por ella
yo matías cuál es el modo de cambiar mi
rol en casa
miren
si creemos que tenemos que depositar el
rol de la transformación social en el
estado o en la sanción de leyes nos
vamos a quedar cortos
los varones tenemos que dar un paso
adelante que nos estamos dando
tenemos que ver aquello que no queremos
ver
yo elegí mirar
elegí a hacerme cargo de la parte que me
toca yo elegí participar para
transformar empezando por mi casa
muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]